[Musica]
pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa
pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa
[Musica]
mica male l'ha cambiato che la curia
emoziona e la cambia cena ghera che se
fai la tua abetone
[Musica]
attaccate ha caricati
muta male la cumbia forcella cubi e
emoziona e la coppia barlettana che se
vai là sulla rai
[Musica]
la carica di altri stati cantati casa
attaccata accade calda
[Musica]
la fai la nuova barletta lava il lato
tra la zona
vienna aq napoletana che ti parla sulla
lana e la mia madre e l'ha caricata
[Musica]
caricata
si vota
ciao
[Applauso]
grazie
grazie a tutti io sono pepe leone un
prodotto nostrano diciamo ecco sono
molto contento di essere qui al ted si
dice ogni lasciata è persa ma a volte si
riacciuffano e quindi stasera ci siamo
finalmente bene insomma anche io mi devo
racconta qualcosa per la prossima
canzone vi volevo dire questo più o meno
100 milioni di anni fa
la puglia non esisteva o meglio era
sommersa nel mare infatti ritroviamo i
fossili delle conchiglie sulla mosciano
l'unica cosa che più o meno c'era parte
appunto qualche piccola spruzzo di terra
quella era il gargano che all'epoca era
un'isola non era una penisola perché
appunto la puglia ancora non era emersa
bene non so quanti di voi sanno che c'è
ancora qualche posto dove il gargano
quando lo guardi e ancora un'isola
chissà dove si vede dove il gargano
sembra un'isola bravo bravo ci sono
alcuni posti di barletta dove se tu
guardi il gargano è un'isola dove uno e
su al castello qua però non ci possiamo
venire di solito al tramonto come
stasera quindi non possiamo vederlo
un altro e al braccio però bisogna
arrivare fino in fondo alla lanterna e
quindi è una cosa che si fa più magari
una volta ogni tanto
mentre c'è una ancora un ultimo punto
che all'inizio della spiaggia di ponente
diciamo al bar conchiglia da quelle
parti
se voi andate là alla prima entrata di
ponente là dove sta il primo vialetto da
il gargano è un'isola e nel mese
di giugno inizi di luglio cioè questo
proprio gli ultimi giorni negli
sgoccioli il sole va a tramontare
esattamente in questo posto di mare
ipotetico perché ipotetico perché poi la
gente di fuori ci viene a dire
e vabbè ma è un'illusione ottica a
perché tu mi stai dicendo che nel
tirreno il mare da voi vi entra proprio
nell'acqua e sempre diciamo o è tutto
vero o è tutto falso
in questo momento dell'anno il sole va a
tramontare esattamente fra quello che
sembra la costa che arriva più mezza
dalla fiumana quello che si vede è il
gargano che sembra un'isola l'anno
scorso appena diciamo si è superata la
fase 1 sono andato tutti i giorni a
godermi tramonti al conchiglia e perché
si sono tutti i giorni la giorno è
passato una ragazza sarebbe lunga che mi
ha detto bao bao bar conchiglia e io poi
aspetta un attimo che adesso la
sistemiamo questa ed è la canzone delle
barre conchiglia per tutti voi e fa così
[Musica]
a barre con chi li ha
ciao
album
[Musica]
ogni giorno vengo qua quando il sole se
ne va per vederlo addormentare in mezzo
al guardian che sembra un'isola da cui
sembra un'isola
a roma
ruba
au.par continia
[Musica]
obama
baku e mi viene di cantarlo e
l'immensità del mar
quando guardo il gar che al riguardo al
gargano che sembra un'isola da qui
sembra un'isola
sì ma solo di qua
a tutti va a barre con via
[Musica]
ed il pescatore che fa che sia prima di
salta quando torna ad altra car passerà
da questo bar finestrella sopra ma il
bar con chi
e anche lui voltan tardelli mentita del
mark quando guarda il gargano che sembra
un'isola a lui sembra un'isola
[Musica]
papà
martin via
[Musica]
parco
lo fa
[Musica]
un parco in via alla faccia lavori ed il
pescato che inizia prima di talpa
quando torna ad altra carta serata
questo bar finestrella sopra ma il parco
e beve una birra
e anche lui vuol cantare nell'immensità
del bar quando guarda i gurkha a lui
sembra unito
ma obama
omar continia
[Musica]
ma con via
con chi
quando voi sembra un'isola
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sarebbe finito
un'altra si può che dire ho scritto un
altro brano che si chiama option che sla
reina del mar la regina del mare per
rimanere sempre in tema ed è una canzone
che ho immaginato per insegnare la
storia della dea del mare i bambini ma
anche agli adulti e fa così parte con un
con
come si dice in italiano con con un
entrare con prepotenza nel tamburello
perché io so proprio un rapporto molto
così fa così
[Musica]
subito di limbo
no
che la reina l'arena larino
[Musica]
ma l'azienda
in perio
[Musica]
facciamoci del male
ma
no
[Applauso]